a former official at Cambridge analytic
is sharing what she considers some of
the data firms questionable practices
Brittany Kaiser worked at the
british-based company from 2014 until
this January before the company shut
down Cambridge analytic a processed data
for several Republican clients including
Donald Trump's presidential campaign it
drew attention when it was revealed the
company harvested data from 87 million
unknowing Facebook users and cameras
caught its CEO discussing underhanded
tactics like bribery and sex stings
Kaiser says she wants to speak out now
about what she sees as the Wild West
attitude of data gathering Cambridge
analytic AI has been in the news because
of the use of Facebook data 87 million
Facebook profiles could it be more than
what we know that Cambridge analytic I
had access to in terms of Facebook user
data in terms of what Cambridge analytic
I had access to I know for a fact that
there were more than just the this is
your digital life app that tends to be
getting a lot of press these days that's
the personality quiz that gathered
information on Facebook users and their
friends Britney Kaiser says she knows of
two similar programs Cambridge analytic
a developed to collect information so
what are we looking at here so this was
an all company email she showed us a
twenty fifteen note from a data
scientist behind a quiz called
music walrus he asked colleagues to
share it with family and friends but
added please do not mention that it is
an SCL thing say that a friend of yours
made it and why would the senior data
scientists who'd been working on this
app not want somebody to say that it
came from SCL which is the parent
company of Cambridge and a little guy at
the time Cambridge analytic Oh was
receiving significant press for its
political work and the state of
scientists was probably well aware of
what might have happened in the press if
it looked like that company was
undertaking data collection on social
media but another internal source tells
CBS News the project never launched no
data was collected
he suggests the intention of the email
was to see how the app would grow
organically without the corporate nature
to make it less enticing did anybody
just from a moral standpoint say you
know when you give somebody something
but you're really doing it to get
something else from them that's just not
the way we should behave regardless of
the rules or the regulations I don't
think too many people look back and
question that if you are interacting
with anything on your phone or your
computer it is specifically designed to
collect as much data about you as
possible so that that can then be
monetized I've decided to take the
responsible and ethical decision to
share my experience at the company in
her role as director of business
development Kaiser sold Cambridge
analytic as data analysis services to
both political and corporate clients
about 30 states prohibit voter data from
being used for commercial purposes and
Kaiser questions whether that might have
happened there is not proper legislation
or regulation or technology available to
track and trace the usage of that data
and I think going forward there needs to
be a better solution for making sure
that agency is much bigger than
Cambridge analytic as well are playing
by the rules what investigators have you
been talking to I'm currently working to
be as helpful as possible to any
government investigations where I can
provide assistance but I can't comment
on that right now while they're ongoing
Kaiser also won't say why she left
Cambridge analytical but she departed in
January before the Facebook scandal
broke and before her former CEO was
exposed on hidden camera Alexander nicks
later denied the company engaged in
dirty political tricks did you know of
any of that or hear of anything like
that while you were there never it's so
disappointing to see things like that in
the media in fact I haven't even been
able to bring myself to watch those
videos I saw enough of the quotes to to
know that I didn't want to know more
when you saw those quotes did you think
I can't believe it or did you think well
mmm I thought it sounded like an
overblown sales pitch like he had gone
above and beyond the call of duty to
explain what was possible in order to
win I had never heard him say anything
like that before so I was shocked and
embarrassed in your feeling having
worked there was was Cambridge analytic
adjust being aggressive with this
exciting new tool or was it breaking the
law
my personal belief was that everybody
was aggressively trying to grow the
company as quickly as possible and just
like another company that's currently
under scrutiny the phrase move fast and
break things I think definitely broke a
lot of things in the last campaign
Kizer there is comparing Cambridge
analytic Oh to Facebook from where that
was the famous Facebook motto we also
talked to Keizer about a visit she paid
to Julian Assange and you can see that
on CBS this morning dot-com former CEO
of Cambridge analytical examiner Nick
says Kaiser is an unreliable witness he
adds the quizzes Kaiser mentioned never
got beyond the testing phase and that
there was nothing nefarious about them
he also told us there were processes in
place to ensure that political data was
not used for commercial purposes well
for people following this story she's
raising some interesting things why is
she talking now do you think well she
says she wants to make sure that this
data collection when regulations are put
in place in the wake of all of this that
they capture sort of everything that was
going on that might be problematic it
was a word she used a lot she only gave
us part of the picture she knows other
things she's talking to investigators
and so we'll know the full picture at
some point later when all of that comes
out mmm good story thank you John